avant la veillée de noël au front
national la purge continue puisque le
bureau exécutif de jean marie le pen a
exclu pour motif grave si proche de
l'ancien délégué général bruno mégret
profitant de cette situation de crise
interne au front national
l'équipe de charlie hebdo a déposé
auprès de l'institut national de la
propriété industrielle la marque front
national aussi curieux que cela puisse
paraître les militants frontistes avait
oublié de le faire et cette initiative
de l'hebdomadaire satirique ne se veut
pas seulement une farce reportage album
nicosie et bernard conner s'il est un
parti politique qui porte son nom en
étendard c'est bien le front national
mais ce nom n'avait jamais été déposée
officiellement charlie hebdo a profité
de ce flou juridique une déclaration
auprès de l'institut de la propriété
industrielle et le tour est joué
ce dépôt concerne les affiches
prospectus et autres colloques portant
la mention front national la rédaction
de l'hebdomadaire s'amuse de ce pied de
nez d'autant qu'il permet une leçon
d'histoire
l'appellation front national tout est
parfait le nom d'un réseau de résistance
pour quand il pas chic anti nazis
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale et
que ces résistants ce centre et l'usure
paix
le nom parfait jean la part des gens
comme les grecs car ce qui peut
apparaître au départ comme un canular de
journalistes provocateur repose sur un
fondement sérieux
ce dépôt sera très probablement
enregistrer d'ici la fin janvier
si on arrive à démontrer qu'en fait ce
n'est pas monsieur jean marie le pen qui
a créé ce nom de front national mais
finalement il a repris d'une institution
d'une société qui existait en ailleurs
mots on pourrait peut-être en faisant
intervenir cette antériorité démonter l
usage qui a été fait par jean marie le
pen
voilà qui embarrasserait sérieusement
les amis de jean marie le pen ainsi que
leurs frères ennemis proches de bruno
mégret surtout dans l'optique des
élections européennes
il s'agit d'une opération bouffonne est
illégal dans la tradition de ce journal
gauchiste au érotique et par conséquent
cela n'a aucune espèce de valeur
juridique
la querelle autour du vocable front
national devrait déboucher sur une
action en justice la question est qui
des lepénistes ou des mégrétistes
attaquera en premier